et on commence donc cette émission avec
Rachid tu es mal merci de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénateur socialiste
du Val-d'Oise on va évidemment parler
longuement de la réforme des retraites
avec vous on va voir ce qui s'est passé
à l'Assemblée mais d'abord journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui c'est la
troisième est-ce que vous espérez encore
pouvoir faire reculer le gouvernement
sur le fond de ce texte je pense que
cette proposition de régression sociale
qui est la retraite à 65 ans 64 ans
pardon ça c'était pour la droite 64 ans
les massivement les Français la
rejettent et je crois que c'est bien
pour le gouvernement d'entendre c'est
une forme injuste je l'ai dit je crois
aussi dangereuse pour les Français en
termes de ce qu'elle propose Escal
impose et il y a pas de raison
d'ailleurs le président du conseil de
rotation des retraites le même le dit il
y a pas de risque contrairement à ce que
j'entendu avec Monsieur Attal il y a pas
de risque aujourd'hui sur le notre
régime de retraite et donc je crois que
les Français souffrent assez de la
période avec les différentes crises que
nous subissons notamment économique
sociale je crois qu'il faut pas faire
cette réforme là et moi je vois
l'amplification
pour le moment mais il dit qu'il y aura
peut-être un problème sur le niveau des
des retraités avec les retraités futurs
viseront peut-être moins bien que la
retraités actuelles
à savoir qu'il y a la question d'abord
donc vous avez dit le premier sujet
c'est que ce que dit le gouvernement
tout ça est démenti par ce président du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites ce
n'est pas rien ce n'est pas rien vous
avez également si vous avez également
vous avez également la question du
Conseil d'État qui a aussi rendu un avis
très dur donc ouais bien la reine bien
frais sur la question des pensions
entraide mais excusez-moi aujourd'hui il
y a un travail notamment sur cette
question là je pense que c'est possible
donc mon nom ce travail là vous voyez on
peut mener ce travail là petit 2 rien
aujourd'hui dans le projet du
gouvernement nous permet de dire qu'il
n'y aura pas un problème de pension de
pension à la fin de cette réforme là
donc si on doit travailler sur un
certain non non les choses sérieuses
aujourd'hui travaillons sur l'emploi des
seniors puisque un Français sur deux
n'arrive pas en activité à la retraite
ça veut dire que notre modèle c'est dire
au Seigneur ce qui nous écoute votre fin
de vie et deux ans de plus de main si la
réforme est acceptée ça sera soit le
chômage soit les minima sociaux est-ce
que c'est un modèle la réponse deuxième
réforme la différence aujourd'hui qui
existe entre les hommes et les femmes
dans leur niveau troisième réforme les
pensions à les pensions notamment liées
aux carrières hachées et que cette
morcelés et puis dernier élément qui me
semble aussi essentiel c'est
effectivement de se dire que par exemple
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que il y a
une différence de 6 à 7 ans 8 ans entre
un ouvrier un cas donc on peut aussi
imaginer que la question de la
pénibilité soit pris en compte ouais
c'est 4 points là je crois qu'on
pourrait faire qu'on s'en sus pour
améliorer le système ce qui n'est pas ce
qu'il proposait aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
dit à discuter de ces points non plus
comment va-t-il faire puisque il fait le
choix d'un projet déjà ficelé dans un
cadre budgétaire et donc toutes les
bonnes choses que j’évoque là ne sont
pas dans la dans le projet prenons
l'emploi des seigneurs gouvernement dit
au salarié ce sera 64 ans pas de
discussion par contre pour la question
de la paix de la du travail des seniors
il faut contraindre personnes il y a un
problème de niveau autre églisant
il faut des sanctions pour vous pour les
entreprises qui ne respectent pas qui
ont des mauvaises pratiques comme ça la
première ministre d'un côté on vous
trouve une solution en disant 64% pour
tout le monde c'est sec et de l'autre il
faudra qu'on imagine des choses mais
pourquoi alors on ne fait pas jusqu'au
bout pareil sur la question du travail
des femmes et notamment différencié
puisque le ministre Franck Richter
lui-même ministre dans la soupements a
dit oui c'est vrai ce sera plus dur
demain pour les femmes que cela
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien comment
pouvez accepter cette discussion là dans
ce sens là donc c'est pour ça nous nous
contestons cette régression sociale et
cette réformation de 4 ans et nous
disons voilà je viens de citer quatre
points sur lequel pour le coup là je
crois qu'avec d'abord les partenaires
sociaux mais également les Français et
puis bien sûr les élus nous pourrions
améliorer le système pour à la fin faire
en sorte que les gens vivent mieux parce
que la retraite c'est quoi c'est un
temps vous dites j'ai travaillé toute ma
vie et enfin je peux profiter de ma vie
mais comment vous allez vous faire
entendre ici dans l'émission du Sénat ou
ou la droite sénatoriale est plutôt
favorable à cette réforme
est-ce que ce que je viens d'évoquer
c'est ce que serait pour moi donc
réforme donc contrairement
vous voyez que la gauche est capable de
faire des propositions concrètes
d'avancer sur ce que vous me dites par
rapport ici dans l'hémicycle au Sénat
nous les socialistes nous avons deux
éléments d'abord un le gouvernement qui
va venir avec cette réforme néfaste et
de la droite qui va dire d'ailleurs sera
intéressant puisque ici chaque année il
y en a un moment qui est voté pour la
réforme à 65 ans mais j'entends
également chez les LR de notre côté que
ce serait 64 ans vous allez tout à
l'heure écouter accueillir Aurélien
Pradier qui je comprends lui-même pose
un centre de questions il dit qu'à ce
stade là si les réponses ne sont pas
arrivées pour ce moment notamment il
vaut très content donc on verra ce que
fera la droite ce que nous ferons nous
les socialistes c'est nous sont comme
toujours nous ferons un débat serein un
débat sur le fond nous aurons des
positions fermes et avec des
propositions concrètes et la droite
sénatoriale qui est parti pour les 64
ans et qui a voté les 64 ans
je ne suis pas là présentant je ne suis
que vice-présent du groupe le moins
socialiste et pas LR on va voir comment
se sont passés les débats hier du côté
de l'Assemblée nationale puisque le
début de séance a été particulièrement
agité notamment en raison de la volonté
de la nuque de se faire entendre sur la
motion référendaire on voit ça avec Alex
tout ça
[Musique]
et Alex le débat à l'Assemblée a
commencé dans une ambiance électrique
hier et oui une entame de débat
extrêmement tendu en cause les fameuses
motions référendaires ces textes déposés
par l'opposition pour organiser un
référendum sur la réforme des retraites
le problème c'est qu'une seule motion
référendaire ne peut être discutée et
c'est la motion du rassemblement
national qui avait été tiré au sort pour
être débattu mais à la dernière minute
hier et bien une troisième motion
référendaire et bien après à la motion
du rassemblement national et celle de la
gauche une troisième motion référendaire
déposée par le groupe Liot liberté
indépendant outre-mer et soutenu par la
gauche a été déposé et c'est gros
politique on multiplié les prises de
parole pendant la séance pour examiner
cette nouvelle motion référendaire on va
écouter Mathilde panot à la présidente
du groupe la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée nationale
cela s'appelle une manœuvre et nous la
voyons gros lorsque cette troisième
motion référendaire a été déposée elle a
été déposée monsieur de course sur la
très bien dit elle a été déposée dans
les délais il n'y a aucune raison pour
que vous rejetiez cette troisième motion
référendaire si ce n'est de rajouter
encore un déni démocratique au coup de
force que vous êtes en train de faire au
million de Français qui manifestent dans
ce pays
voilà dans ce début d'examen de la
réforme des retraites le débat a été
complètement paralysé par cette querelle
de règlement notamment avec les prises
de parole de la gauche et Marine Le Pen
a souhaité rappeler les contrats les
contradictions de la gauche autour de
cette motion référendaire on va
l'écouter
nous avons proposé à l'ensemble des
groupes qui ont déposé la motion les six
groupes on leur a dit écoutez nous on
est prêt à retirer la nôtre si vous
acceptez la signature des députés
rassemblement national pour qu'il y ait
véritablement une motion transpartisane
et jusqu'à présent vous avez refusé
alors maintenant alts
voilà ça c'est pour la réponse de Marine
Le Pen dans ce débat alors dans un bras
continue alimenter notamment par la
gauche de l'hémicycle et bien le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft a
essayé de prendre la parole pour lancer
enfin le débat sur la réforme des
retraites mais impossible pour lui de
s'exprimer regardez
madame la Présidente de la Commission de
l'affaire sociale
mesdames et messieurs mesdames le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous y sommes monsieur le ministre on va
suspendre 5 minutes le temps que c'est
Herstal collègue laisse le gouvernement
s'exprimer
rachithéma est-ce que c'est digne de la
part de députés de gauche notamment de
paralyser le débat ainsi pour une
querelle de règlement au point de ne pas
laisser un ministre s'exprimer il y a
plusieurs choses
référendum parce que moi je l'ai écouté
et elle était très parfaite parce que
faudrait expliquer à vos explicateurs
du règlement intérieur de l'Assemblée du
courant qui a une possibilité de déposer
de mention référendaire juste avant la
décision générale ce qui a fait le
groupe liote bon et donc il y avait donc
sur la table trois notions référendaires
ce qui n'est pas entendable
c'est que le la présence de l'Assemblée
n'a pas fait un an ce choix-là elle a
dit la troisième je ne la prends pas
donc elle ne pouvait pas dire cela c'est
ce qui a créé d'ailleurs la prise de
position de valéraux qui a été sur le
fond comme sur la forme très claire
comme à son habitude d'ailleurs on peut
aussi se rappeler les propos de Jérôme
gage également qui ont été l'un comme
l'autre très clair très respectueux des
institutions donc ce que font les
socialistes par ces deux prises de
parole là c'est très c'est très
respectueux du débat des débat
parlementaire vous me parlez d'autre
politique moi je ne suis pas là pour
faire du commentaire je vous parle des
miens
socialistes aux côtés des insoumis sur
ce que des communistes il y a pas écrit
que on doit juger ou doit être caution
ou doit être responsable des propos des
autres moi je vous parle des propos de
Valéry Rabault et de Jérôme gage et
c'est dommage qu'ils ne sont que vous
n'avez pas passer il y a aucun problème
ni sur le fond ni sur la forme
une stratégie d'agitation et encore une
fois moi je suis pour le débat dans
l'hémicycle au Sénat et à l'Assemblée je
dis juste que je trouve assez
regrettable parce que vous oubliez le
fait générateur que la présence de
l'assurance nationale n'est pas accepté
d'appliquer son propre règlement parce
que il y avait 3motions auquel cas il
fallait à ce moment-là faire mon ce
tirage au sort parce que c'était
l'option qui a été choisi par la
Conférence des Présidents quand au
passage de Madame Le Pen oui nous ne
finirons jamais rien avec Madame Le Pen
nous combattons l'extrême droite
l'extrême droite est un danger pour ce
pays un danger pour les Français un
danger pour les travailleurs donc on n'a
pas de le soir le manneupen je le redis
puisque d'ailleurs ce vernis d'ailleurs
ça c'est effectivement une régression
sociale sans précédent ça va nous peine
devait appuyer son projet donc oui nous
signons rien avec Madame Le Pen alors
vous n'avez pas les mêmes problèmes
politiques mais même au point de ne pas
signer une émotion référendum parce que
finalement vous aviez dans le même
objectif organisé un référendum sur la
réforme des retraites il y a un moment
donné
des principes fondamentaux l'extrême
droite on ne l'espèce le rassemblement
national à deux origines génétiques
les anciens de la collaboration avec le
régime nazi et les anciens lois rien
chez Madame Le Pen et son mouvement nous
nous est acceptable nous combattons jour
après jour ce mouvement là ces idées là
donc je ne signerons jamais rien avec
elle nous tiendrons
juste sur le rassemblement national
puisque Marine Le Pen a fait tailler de
menaces à l'encontre de députés et es de
son groupe qui aurait reçu des appels
leur indiquant qu'un de leurs proches
avaient été hospitalisés dans un hôpital
de leur circonscription des appels
anonymes pour les faire quitter
l'hémicycle alors qu'une notion
référendaire ne peut pas passer si tout
le monde n'est pas présent vous
condamnez ce type de pratique
je condamne toute agression tout injure
toute menace vers qui que ce soit en
général et dans l'espèce là sur ce débat
là pour tous les parlementaires je fais
la différence je fais la différence
monsieur Bardella s'il a des preuves
alors il faut déposer plainte et laisser
les autorités judiciaires et des pôles
la police venaient leur enquête sinon
sinon il y a un nom pour cela donc moi
je pense que là aussi il faut que
Monsieur bordel et d'autres redescende
s'il y a eu des menaces auquel cas il
faut déposer plainte et moi je souhaite
que les personnes qui sont responsables
de cela soit identifiés et condamné
lourdement au-delà de cette querelle de
règlement qui a duré
c'est pas je j'en c'est important c'est
important
on les respecte c'est tout moi je c'est
pas une querelle en tout cas pour les 70
indiquez la position
totale 20 000 amendements ont été
déposés sur la réforme des retraites
dont 18000 de la part de la nupes si
jamais le temps d'examen était illimité
ça ferait 40 semaines de débat est-ce
que selon vous c'est l'obstruction
clairement alors moi je l'ai socialiste
je crois qu'on était assez mesurées pour
les socialistes et port de débats
importants d'abord le droit d'amendement
c'est quand même comme dirait un certain
avec nous c'est quand même l'oxygène des
parlementaires donc moi je suis pour le
respect du droit des parlementaires à
déposer un amendements bon mais donc moi
je ne suis pas pour l'obstruction mais
je ne suis pas en même temps pour
l'utilisation d'un texte s'appelle au 47
le 47,1 qui limite les débats ouais
c'est un moment donné je pense que c'est
comme la dissuasion nucléaire il faut
que tout le monde redescende donc moi
j'aurais aimé que look Valmont dise on a
un texte je comptais ce texte mais on a
un texte et il y a un débat et donc ça
prend le temps que ça prendra plutôt que
d'utiliser cette méthode là et pour le
coup moi je souhaite comme le soit
d'ailleurs les députés socialistes qu'un
débat notamment l'article 7 puisque
c'est là où il y a la question des 64
ans il faut mener ce débat là justement
on va parler du fond puisque le débat a
pu avoir lieu finalement entre la gauche
et le gouvernement mais oui puisque les
oppositions avaient aussi déposé une
motion de rejet de ce texte et notamment
la gauche qui est dénonçait une réforme
qui est refusée par une majorité de
Français et les députés de gauche
proposent pour réduire le déficit futur
de notre régime des retraites il propose
non pas de travailler plus longtemps
mais d'augmenter les cotisations dans
certains cas écoutez ce que leur a
répondu Gabriel Attal le ministre des
comptes publics
vous proposez de
texte mais qui fait des
heures de tiers des ouvriers pas les
milliardaires
vous proposez de renchérir massivement
le coup du travail qui subirait le
retour du chômage de masse les salariés
pas les milliardaires
vous proposez de surtaxer
l’intéressement et la participation qui
en bénéficient dans notre pays 5
millions de salariés pas les
milliardaires
on a entendu les propositions que vous
faisiez pour une meilleure réforme des
retraites selon vous mais est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord aussi avec l'idée
qu'il faut augmenter les cotisations
notamment sur les dividendes
je me suis atteint et très doué dans la
rhétorique mais le problème c'est que
moi alors moi j'ai aucun problème avec
les milliardaires donc j'ai pas de c'est
pas mon sujet mais c'est marrant parce
que dans ce débat là et vous quand vous
entendez notamment le syndicat tout
n'est pas mis sur la table c'est-à-dire
que c'est une réforme on vous dit ça ça
on ne touche pas autre ça moi je
conseille encore une fois si on veut
faire un vrai débat mettons tout sur la
table la question des cotisations c'est
un sujet la question de d'avoir des
recettes supplémentaires souvenez-vous à
l'époque un premier s'appelle Lionel
Jospin avait créé un fond spécifique de
la réforme des retraits vous savez sur
des sur justement des dividendes à
l'époque de grands groupes parce que la
croissance allait mieux on peut nager
plein de choses ce qui moi me choque
c'est qu'avec ce globalement là c'est
qu'on ne peut pas débattre on ne peut
pas débattre c'est-à-dire qu'ils vous
disent alors voilà toutes ces options là
vous n'y touchez pas il y a une seule
voie en fait leur problème c'est le
concept de la pensée unique à part leur
position il y a rien d'autre voilà donc
moi je pense qu'un débat doit être
ouvert et sur un et je le redis pour que
tout le monde soit bien clair le
concertation des retraites par son
président indique que d'abord sera
minime et donc tout ça et on peut demain
faire mieux parce que si demain il y a
plus d'emplois ça veut dire plus de
cotation et on peut compenser le léger
déficit qu'il y a oh parce que c'est 3%
- 3% ou 0,3 % pardon 03 % pardon
excusez-moi ce matin 0,3 % donc il y a
pas de sujet on peut le gérer on a
suggéré verger je rappelle que
aujourd'hui les comptes ne sont pas dans
le rouge donc tout ça et donc possible
mais là on voit bien que c'est une
réforme comptable et c'est une réforme
idéologique ce gouvernement là quoi
qu'il en coûte veut faire passer cette
réforme là parce que à la fin d'isolons
français à la fin c'est maintenir le
même niveau de pension aujourd'hui si
vous avez donc plus de retraités pour le
même gâteau alors vous allez baisser les
pensions c'est ce que propose ce
gouvernement là derrière sa pseudo bonne
gestion merci Alex merci on revient tout
à l'heure évidemment on parlera avec
vous de cette journée d'hier sur le
Parti socialiste est-ce que le Parti
socialiste va parler d'une même voix sur
ce texte notamment sur la question de
l'âge de départ
ce que j'ai cru comprendre des
parlementaires à l'Assemblée il n'y a
pas de débat sur les amendements il y en
aura pas non plus il y en aura pas non
plus sur la question 62 ans
c'est la position qui a été votée par
tout le socialisme moi je n'étais pas
parlementaire
sous le bouquinat de François Hollande
beaucoup de mes collègues quittaient à
l'Assemblée le soir encore ils ont voté
son centre de réformes je crois qu'il
faut un peu de cohérence je crois qu'on
est capable nous de dire on a fait cette
réforme à l'époque mais je vous rappelle
que on a fait les carrières longues ce
qui est pas dire c'est une grande
avancée avec beaucoup de Français qui
partent à 60 ans avec notamment la
question à la bilité d'entrer dans l'âge
etc ils ont fait la pénibilité et la
pénibilité l'homme qui a retiré la
pénibilité du débat et de
l'agitation c'est Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron
c'est une erreur pour vous le retour de
l'âge légal de départ à 60 ans
je vous ai dit qu'il y a une cohérence à
avoir donc je maintiens la cohérence que
nous avons porté avec avec justement la
pénibilité qui permet des gens de partir
beaucoup plus tôt et la question des
carrés longs je crois que c'est beaucoup
mieux et nous y ajoutons comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure la question de travail
des seniors la question des femmes la
question des carrières arrachées etc et
ça c'est ça nous ne sommes pas une
réforme
pour les Français pas régressive c'est
la différence avec d'autres est-ce que
la page de congrès socialiste est
tournée en tout cas moi je considère
qu'il y a eu un accord il y a eu un
pacte de gouvernance de responsabilité
entre les trois notions qui étaient
soumises au vote des socialistes le
parti vous l'avez vu était coupé en deux
parce qu'il y avait voilà et maintenant
il faut que je crois tout le monde
travaille parce que l'idée c'est quoi
c'est que je crois qu'en 2027 il y a un
risque d'extrêmement notre pays et je
crois que seul la gauche peut battre
l'extrême droite et la gauche quand elle
a je crois j'ai envie de dire un centre
de gravité qui permet de rassembler très
largement et je crois que c'est autour
du Parti socialiste donc le rôle du
partialiste il est historique dans cette
période là c'est une refondation
idéologique organisationnelle mais aux
fondations idéologique pour proposer aux
Français un vrai projet de société et
donc moi je crois que je vais m'y
atteler avec d'autres et je crois que
c'est ce qui doit nous guider
collectivement dans la période qui vient
de s'ouvrir mais ça veut dire être
moteur de l'union de la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la France
insoumise est-ce que le Parti socialiste
peut être moteur de cette vidéo
fibre aujourd'hui quand vous regardez le
nombre de parlementaires le nombre
d'élus ce sont les socialistes qui sont
responsabilités il faut sûrement il faut
assumer notre rôle mais ça passe d'abord
par nous-mêmes c'est-à-dire par
nous-mêmes se dire voilà ce que nous
pensons pour les Français et ensuite
nous rassemblerons à la fois la gauche
mais également les Français donc je
pense c'est dans cet ordre là qu'il faut
prendre les choses pour pas se
déterminer
une direction aujourd'hui qui est
collégiale à plans ça comme on veut et
je crois qu'il faut il y a un premier
secrétaire de l'église s'appelle Nicolas
may Rossignol une première secrétaire
déléguée qui s'appelle Johanna Roland
Hélène Geoffroy et président du Conseil
slash je vois que oui là il y a un pack
qui s'appelle Olivier document le
document qui est signé il y a bien écrit
direction collégiale et on va pas avoir
une discussion sémantique ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que est-ce que ils
sont rassemblent après Marseille moi je
l'ai souhaité je le souhaite toujours et
je crois que c'est la bonne voie on va
voir l'actualité dans nos régions avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
on va à Montpellier on retrouve les
vieux Biscaye bonjour Olivier merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeur des
rédactions du Midi Libre on va parler
un autre sujet avec vous de la possible
probable futur et forme des institutions
Olivier vous avez signé dimanche dans
votre journal un édito pas touche à
l'Occitanie
pas de touche à l'Occitanie un effet
parce que cette cette édito aux essuie à
une rencontre qui a eu lieu entre
Emmanuel Macron et François Hollande le
président de la république ayant annoncé
une possible réforme des institutions et
une de ces lubies c'est-à-dire rediviser
redécoupés quelques-unes des régions
françaises installées sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande dont
l'occitanier donc là je dis pas tout je
dis non parce que j'estime que s'amuser
avec la carte des territoires commence à
bien faire au nom de quoi d'ailleurs de
quelle logique politique de quelle
ambition économique on oublie trop
souvent que cet ensemble de 13
départements s'est installé malgré les
antagonistes malgré les hostilités
historiques et ça marche et c'est ce que
je développe dans cet édito ça marche au
plan économique sur l'accompagnement des
projets on ne se rend pas compte combien
une région comme l'Occitanie aussi
puissante pousse les projets les
initiatives et a fait en sorte de passer
des crises il suffit de voir qui s'est
produit pendant le covid pendant la
crise économique et sociale et voir
comment cette région qui s'est installée
aidé les citoyens les collectivités les
entreprises et puis un dernier point
comment redécouper une région 8 ans
après son installation sans se poser la
question des départements des autres
collectivités en revenant sur le
conseiller territoire réel digne de
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est de là ne plus rien
y comprendre donc j'ai dit tout
simplement à Emmanuel Macron dans mon
édito altela monsieur le Président et
c'est ce que je dis aussi au sénateur
Rachid tu es mal est-ce qu'ils
voteraient une nouvelle une énième
réforme des institutions est-ce qu'on a
vraiment que ça à faire en ce moment
on vient d'évoquer il y a une crise
sociale sans précédent il y a une crise
économique il y a aussi une crise
climatique il y a une question
démocratique il y a la réforme de
retraite pour les français très
honnêtement c'est avoir peur toute la
journée et là on leur dit bah là paf on
avait vexé à faire on rajoute une
réformationnelle dont personne Neder ce
qu'il y a dedans bon j'ai bien compris
que le président veut marquer son
histoire donc il veut une réforme je
trouve qu'elle a pas beaucoup de sens
voir pas du tout si je prends la
question de l'Oxy je crois que Carole
Delga qui a été brillamment réélu
afin d'exon travail vous avez raison de
le rajouter notamment quand il était agi
de traiter la question du covid on a eu
raison et on a un bien fait d'avoir les
régions avec nous pour voir le faire
donc un peu de respect pour ceux qui ont
travaillé on parle souvent des premiers
de corvées il faut le rendre hommage
parce que fait pas d'ailleurs la réforme
de retraite et je pense qu'il faut aussi
rendre hommage à ce que font les régions
donc là où ça fonctionne il faut laisser
fonctionner traitement quand j'entends
en Occitanie je sais le rôle notamment
je pense notamment à l'industrie
aéronautique importante le travail qui
est fait notamment pour développer le
train dans cette région là très
honnêtement d'expliquer maintenant on va
tout casser mais pourquoi faire pour
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut éviter
maintenant cela donc je ne voterai pas
cette réforme là si elle devait arriver
bien je vois beaucoup en réformer les
institutions ou alors proposons des
choses sérieuses mais je veux dire c'est
pour juste casser des régions on pensait
dire qu'à un moment donné on a besoin de
le projet à l'époque de l'Occitanie par
exemple c'est d'avoir des régions
suffisamment grandes et puissantes pour
concurrencer d'autres régions parce que
aujourd'hui il y a aussi cette forme de
concurrence d'autres régions notamment
en Europe et d'avoir des outils
puissants qui parle de rassembler c'est
aujourd'hui le notamment quand vous
regardez l'Occitanie donc en fait on
propose quoi la place de réduire un fait
des petites régions d'empêcher le
déploiement d'empêcher la concurrence
avec de grandes régions notamment je
pense Hollander quel sens cela aurait
donc arrêtons la bidouille je pense que
c'est mieux je veux dire aujourd'hui la
question qui est pose le français c'est
comment ils vivent mieux la question
donc ça s'appelle la question la
rémunération du salaire ça s'appelle la
question du logement c'est la question
la pression d'une transport la sécurité
de l'emploi c'est des situations sur
lequel on a besoin des régions les
régions c'est notamment le transport
c'est totalement l'éducation est à mon
travers des lycées de la formation
professionnelle c'est aussi la
solidarité qui est qui est fait avec
d'autres d'autres départements etc voilà
et dont les les régions se développer je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
régions droit toute gauche comme les
départements et les et les les villes
explique que la politique du
gouvernement qui depuis 5 ans réduit
leurs recettes réduit leur liberté
d'investissement pénalise le pays et
pour terminer pour pas être trop long je
rappelle que notre pays
70% d'investissement public donc il fait
tourner l'économie notamment le bâtiment
et d'autres vient des collectivités donc
un peu de respect pour celles et ceux
qui financent notre l'économie notre
pays merci Olivier
biscuit merci Olivier réforme des
retraites à l'Assemblée le bras de fer
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première
oui on fera un petit point météo un
petit peu plus tard même si je sais que
vous voulez pas parler météo mais vous
avez réussi à le placer merci beaucoup
racheter mal d'avoir été avec nous dans
le club des têtes on verra comment on se
prépare la mobilisation dans nos régions
ça dans le Grand Est en Bretagne et puis
débat entre la députée communiste
elsafossions et la députée Renaissance
Prisca théveno ce sera à suivre d'abord
on accueille notre prochaine invité sur
Aurélien Pradier